foreign
let's imagine together we've gone on an
eight-month journey and arrived to the
planet Mars yes Mars
somehow we'll have to figure out how to
build protective and durable structures
to Shield us against solar radiation
Galactic cosmic rays and extreme
temperature swings
on a Mars mission there's only so much
that we can bring with us from Earth and
it's prohibitively expensive to launch
tons and tons of construction materials
into space
so
to realize a pioneering habitat that
progressively grows adapts and expands
into a permanent Outpost
we have to think differently about how
we build
these habitats and the robots that build
them will enable Humanity to thrive
off-world
I am a space architect I design and
conceive habitats supporting human
exploration in deep space like on the
surface of Mars not only do I design
spaces for optimal crew health and
performance but I also investigate what
these habitats are and how they're going
to be built
now Mars is so far from us that
Communications delays can take up to 22
minutes one way to or from Earth and
what that means is that we can't rely on
real-time tele-robotics controlled by
people on Earth to supervise what
happens in construction on mars or for
that matter to supervise anything that
happens when we're exploring the planet
but if we leverage autonomous robotics
we'll send 3D printers and other
construction robots to build protective
habitats and shelters before the crew
even arrives
so
how exactly with 3D printers build a
habitat on Mars
well first we have to figure out what
these structures are made out of
just like early civilizations we'll use
nc2 regolith commonly known as Dart and
other resources that are local and
indigenous to the planet including water
and possibly combine them with additives
and binders that we bring from Earth to
engineer high performance construction
materials
our goal when we're designing these
habitats is to introduce an airtight
structure that can withstand internal
pressurization which is what will allow
people to live in a breathable and
temperate environment on the inside
the robots that we Deploy on Mars will
need to perceive and interpret the
complexity of a construction site in
order to sequence and choreograph
different types of tasks these tasks
will include prospecting Mars and
surveying for a site to build collecting
raw materials processing those materials
and maneuvering them around some of
these Bots might resemble the character
Wally except you know not so cute
once the site has been excavated and
Foundations are printed these structures
are manufactured layer by layer by layer
and as construction progresses pre-built
and pre-integrated Hardware like
airlocks or life support equipment
brought from Earth are inserted into the
print until finally they're sealed at
various connection points
to do more than just survive in space we
need to create environments that
positively contribute to well-being for
months and years into the future and as
more civilian astronauts travel to space
it's important that our environments are
more than the tightly packed mechanical
Interiors of the International Space
Station which today represents the
state-of-the-art for long-duration human
life in space
we also want to incorporate practical
architectural elements such as access to
natural light through windows and
Greenery these were features that were
missing aboard the space station when it
was first commissioned but which we know
are critical to positive psychological
functioning and well-being
for long duration missions in deep space
it's important that crew members feel
less like they're living in a machine
and more like they're living in a home
there are other ways of approaching
Habitat Construction on Mars hard shell
or inflatable structures may not provide
the radiation protection that we need
and living underground in lava tubes
doesn't quite support direct surface
exploration on the planet and also why
would you travel for eight months to
live underground
designing structures in space is all
about mitigating risks and the habitats
that we create will need to be the most
durable and the most resilient
structures ever conceived future
off-world surface habitats will be
self-regulating and self-maintained
structures to support the crew members
while they're there but also to operate
autonomously when they are not
before we send anyone to Mars we need
data to answer some very key questions
about human health safety and to
validate each of these construction
activities
fortunately for us we have a test bed
and approving grounds much much closer
to Earth that's our own Moon
today we're working with NASA to
demonstrate how will 3D print
infrastructure like landing pads
roadways and eventually habitats
directly on the lunar surface the Moon
is a critical Pit Stop to refuel
resupply and serve as a general platform
for vehicles traveling to deep space and
we'll use the Technologies establishing
a permanent human presence on the moon
to travel to from and operate on the
surface of Mars
what else are we doing to advance the
viability of 3D printing for building in
space
well for one thing we can demonstrate
that 3D printed structures can support
people in a mission-like environment
right here on Earth and use data from
those experiments to set standards and
requirements for future Mars missions
this is what we did in designing and
building Mars Dune Alpha a 3D printed
analog habitat at the Johnson Space
Center in Houston referred to as the
crew health and performance exploration
analog that's a really long name I know
this structure will house four volunteer
crew members simulating a one-year
Mission to Mars including a 20-minute
Communications delay the first mission
is kicking off later this year but you
could actually apply to be a crew member
in this habitat sometime in the future
or if you're not so inclined you can
suggest it to someone else in the name
of research
if you're one of the Chosen Few you'll
be sharing 1700 square feet of living
and working areas with three others and
that includes an aeroponic Garden for
plant growth a Communications area an
exercise room as well as individual crew
cabins that are very cozy just six by 12
feet
some of you may be thinking well
building in space this is a topic pretty
far removed from our day-to-day lives
how might it impact what we do on Earth
today
in my experience designing for an
extreme environment that is the most
restrictive and that presents the most
constraint constraints and which
literally no human has ever gone before
is what gives us the best chances of
creatively engineering solutions to
problems here on Earth that seem
completely beyond our graph today
problems like Housing Solutions for the
chronically homeless or hurricane and
disaster relief housing or rethinking
sustainable practices within
construction overall which according to
the UN is responsible for up to 30
percent of carbon emissions worldwide
the autonomous technologies that we
develop for building in space redound to
us on Earth they feed back and pay
dividends to how we reimagine and
reconceive construction happening today
the fact of the matter is that the most
habitable planet is the one we live on
right now
I don't like treating space like it's a
Lifeboat for Humanity from an ailing
planet Earth
we can either solve for how to build
smarter and more sustainably today or
will have to think about designing for
survival on an earth more extreme and
more foreign than any of us have ever
known and this to me cannot be the
primary reason or driver why we explore
and Venture into deep space
it's been over 50 years since any human
has traveled outside of Earth's orbit
things are about to change we will
develop a permanent moon base and we
will build autonomously on Mars we are
on the cusp of seeing radical
transformation and how we build on Earth
and how we push past limits to a new
frontier of human exploration in space
thank you so much
[Applause]